Emily Gorcenski - The Ethics of the Internet
of Things
EMILY: Thank you all very much.
I'm going to talk about the ethics of the
Internet of Things and I promise I'm not going
to lecture you too much.
I'm Emily Gorcenski.
I'm on Twitter.
I say there things sometimes.
I like the Internet of Things and the landscape
it is creating.
So why am I talking about the Internet of
Things at a JavaScript conference?
Why am I talking about ethics at a JavaScript
conference?
It's because I've given this talk a few times
and I joke that every time I give it, I can
give a brand new talk because there are so
many issues, there are so many failures, and
bugs, and security issues that come up so
freakily, so that if I just focus on case
studies, it will be a brand new talk every
time.
This time, I've decided that I don't want
to give this talk any more.
I want you all to be able to give this talk,
so I want to talk a little bit more generally
about why ethics matters and why is should
matter to you as a JavaScript developer and
how we can put technology into all sorts of
devices and services where it doesn't normally
belong.
It's almost impossible to do an ethics talk
without getting into heavy stuff.
There are contents warnings about this talk.
We will talk frankly about some incidents
that resulted in injuries and death of people.
A discussion of a specific instance of sexual
assault and an image of raw meat.
If that spooks you out, that will be maybe
about ten minutes into the talk.
Who am I?
I have a little bit of a confession.
I'm kind of an imposter here.
I'm not a JavaScript developer.
I'm a data scientist and I'm trained as a
mathematician but also an engineer.
I went to school for aeronautical engineering
and mechanical engineering, and I have worked
in my career in the aerospace, biotech, and
now I work in the finance industries.
And what these industries have in common is
that they're all heavily regulated, and most
of the people working in them subscribe to
a professional code of ethics either through
an independent society or some other organisation
that guides what ethical conduct mean.
Here I am, I worked in defence, health care,
and banking, and I'm going to talk to you
about ethics - buckle in!
When I talk about the Internet of Things,
what is it that I mean?
It's kind of a wishy-warranty definition.
We might think about smart fridges or smart
cars, that sort of thing.
I like to think of it as putting the internet
where it doesn't normally belong.
So it could be smart appliances.
I think of Uber as an IoT taxi.
When we look at ethics of that, we have to
look at the entire scope of what are we doing
with our technology and what are we connecting?
The difference isn't that these devices and
products or services haven't been computerised,
it is we're letting the consumer have connectivity
to what is going on.
So, if you're a JavaScript developer, maybe
you want an bread machine so you can hack
your code while the bread bakes.
This is important because IoT products are
the next level of convenience optimisation.
We've spent the last 30 years optimising products
for convenience, and there's not much more
competitive advantage that you can get in
a refrigerator nowadays.
So if you don't have a competitive advantage
with a non-connected device, you have to go
connected.
This is also important for people whose livelihoods
are affected by disability.
You might be concerned about the surveillance
capabilities of IoT devices or the horrible
things that Uber has been accused of doing,
but if you're not able to get around or don't
live in a place where there is an easy taxi
service and you have other needs, something
like Uber is a life -saver and changes your
life.
We can't write it off as an absurdity, say
IoT is frivolous, we have the internet Twitter
account and there are a lot of misses and
there but there are a lot of good things that
come out of IoT as well.
When I talk about ethics, what is it I mean
when I say that word?
You've probably seen this diagram.
The framing goes there is one Nobel Laureate
tied to five set of tracks and another tied
to another.
Somehow, you have been put in the position
of pulling the lever.
This is a really popular problem on the internet
right now because it feels like something
we can solve with category theory if we just
abstract it enough, and, two, it really makes
for some dank memes.
The thing about the trolley problem is the
trolley problem wasn't a problem for trolleys,
so why is it a problem for self-driving cars?
We love to frame things as puzzles to solve
- that is our nature as developers and engineers.
In tech, we don't actually face ethical dilemmas
that often.
Ethical dilemmas happen when there are two
competing ethical frameworks, and an action
that you take cannot not be in violation of
at least one of them.
What I think is fascinating about JavaScript
is that the JavaScript community is responsible
for what I consider to be the most fascinating
true ethical dilemma in a decade of technology.
I will get to you on that later.
Some might know what I'm talking about already.
The issue of technology is that often we just
don't act with ethics.
I don't mean this as an indictment saying
you're bad, unethical, immoral human beings.
There are some companies out there that will
get a side eye right now, but I mean in our
industry, we don't have a professional code.
There are some societies that you can join,
but raise your hand if you're a member of
like ACM or I888.
There are a few out there but it is not the
majority.
In practice, ethics are about things: they
are about the analysis of harm and the mitigation
of risk.
So, when we talk about acting ethically, especially
in something like research ethics, what we
are doing is we're not trying to eliminate
the possibility of somebody getting hurt,
but we are trying to understand all of the
ways that somebody might be hurt by our technology,
and we're looking for what actions we can
take to mitigate the chance of that happening,
to mitigate the severity of it when it happens,
and to provide remediation when it inevitably
does.
So this is what we need to bid up as our ethical
framework when we are developing technology
particularly for IoT.
So harm can happen in three ways: ment first
is through malfeasance.
This is the most common topic in IoT.
This is security.
This is people talking about hacking.
When the Miri botnet had a DS attack last
fall, it was the biggest issue, the big I
est DOS attack witnessed happened through
IoT devices that were unsecured and you know
that IoT security is in a pretty abysmal state
right now.
When this happened, the timing of it and the
way that it was structured gave a lot of people
a lot of concerns that it was a precursor
to an attack on the US presidential election,
and that would be an attempt to influence
the outcome of that election as it turns out,
the fears were unfounded - we managed to screw
that one up all by ourselves - because I don't
want to talk about security in this talk.
First, I can't cover everything; succeeded,
the other ways that harm can happen, if we
address those, we address the security issues.
Failures are failures in bugs and software.
Cases happen when a device is operating under
normal operating circumstances, but it gets
put into a condition that we did not predict
as developers.
It is also worth mentioning that sometimes
we like to treat ... difference except for
semantics.
So a great example of this, this was on Twitter.
This poor gentleman, Andrew, had an IoT water
cooler, and his TLS certificate expired, which
led to some blocking code which meant that
a hardware interlock failed and he has water
all over his house.
This is a real issue, right?
This is a problem.
If a TLS certificate expire in a web service,
like in a web space, and we forget the TLS
certificate and we have a blocking code, we
have ops people to deal with that.
We can't treat IoT devices like cattle any
more, we have to treat them like pets that
live in people's homes and get very, very
angry when they don't get fed.
One day, if we're not careful, we are going
to put JavaScript into, I don't know, an IoT
kettle and light somebody's house on fire
because "undefined" is not a function.
I stole that joke, by the way which is total
payback because he didn't save me MPM socks!
This is something that I did, I'm very proud
of, this.
I did this a couple of years ago am I did
full screen on this if I can, if I can figure
out where my mouse is - there we go.
This is a Microsoft band - and I'm not picking
on Microsoft at all here - and this is a piece
of raw chicken.
I didn't do horrible to a chicken like have
a zombie chicken out there, this is a piece
of meat that I bought from the grocery score.
It is reading a heart rate of 120 beats per
minute!
[Laughter].
In the real world, sensors are messy, they're
noisy, they're imperfect.
And so, when we are designing for IoT, we
have to take this into consideration.
It is absurd that you can read a heart rate
off a piece of chicken breast, but this has
deep, deep ramifications for a lot of things.
For one, there are colleges out there that
are mandating students wear FitBits.
There are employers out there that have health
insurance incentive programs for doing this.
If you're following what is happening with
American health care, now we have this issue
where we have surveillance devices that are
monitoring our health and can report on pre-existing
conditions.
This is not actually hypothetical, this is
something that's really happened.
Let me get out of full-screen mode if I can.
2015, a woman was visiting a co-worker.
She pulled police to report a sexual assault.
When the police investigated they found her
fit bit, and with her permission, they analysed
the data.
When they analysed the data, not only did
they drop the investigation into her claims,
but they turned around and they charged her
with making false statements to the police,
and, last year, she completed guilty to those
charges and was convicted and put on probation.
The prosecuting attorney said that the FitBit
data sealed the deal.
I can pull 120 beats per minute off a piece
of raw chicken and a woman's life is ruined
because nobody at FitBit stood up and said
no, our devices are not this accurate.
You can't do that.
Our devices bear false witness against us,
and they can.
The problem is there is no regulation, quality
assurance or standards for how we build them.
We just ship code.
We ship hardware.
We innovate, fast, fast, fast.
We don't ask ourselves what kinds of harm
can happen when this goes wrong?
And this is happening increasingly often.
These devices are being used in criminal and
civil investigations.
Just last week, CNN reported that a man is
being charged with murder of his wife based
on the FitBit data saying she had travelled
a certain distance and that distance didn't
correlate with his story.
Anybody that is knitted, for example, while
wearing one will know that it will record
steps while you're sitting on your couch.
How can we let this happen?
How can we let this information affect people's
lives?
Another incident: a smart water metre was
used in a murder investigation last year.
In the same investigation, they also filed
a warrant for Amazon Echo data.
The question is: who's going to go to jail?
Who's going to get put on probation when a
device makes false statements to the police?
Moreover, say something happens, say something
breaks and somebody gets hurt or somebody
gets killed?
Who's going to be liable if that device causes
an accident?
Is it the owner?
Is it the developer?
The company that made it?
And this seems like it should be a settled
question, but it is actually not.
And this is has already happened.
In this frame, you will see the vehicle, the
white vehicle on the right is a Google self-driving
car, and this image is a still image - this
is a screen capture from a video taken from
the dashcam of a municipal bus in Mountain
View California.
That Google SUV is about to pull out in front
of the bus and get in an accident.
Thankfully, nobody was hurt in this.
There were no injuries, just a fender-bender.
This is the first time that the self-driving
car has ever been found responsible for causing
an accident.
Google fessed up to.
They said, "You know what?
Our bad.
We will take care of the damages."
And they investigated what happened, and they
concluded that the car predicted that the
bus would yield to us because we were ahead
of it.
Okay, now Google is in a position right now
where they want to ship self-driving cars,
so of course they're going to assume liability
for this because they don't want to test it
in court.
But we can't rely on that as we go into the
IoT future.
We can't rely on benevolent corporations to
assume liability once this goes out at scale.
By the way, even if Google was right this
is still going to be an historical moment
because, if the bus had yielded to the vehicle,
it would be the first time that a municipal
bus has ever yielded!
A few years ago, there's a judge in San Francisco,
and this is part of a research project, not
part of a case, he looked into the question
of whether autonomous systems fall under existing
theories of liability.
And in looking into it, he found that vehicles
that make our own decisions, that use things
like neural nets that use adaptive self-adjusting
control systems, smart systems, if you will,
devising their own means to attain a task
may not be subject to liability under any
existing theories of tort.
And this has huge implications.
Because if you buy a normal refrigerator and
it breaks, you can say, "Hey, manufacturer,
you're responsible for that break."
If you buy a coffee-maker and it burns down
your house because of a defective unit, you
can get out safely and then you recover damages
from the company and your insurance company
takes care of it.
There's a whole ethical framework that's built
up around this.
And there's a legal structure that's there
as well.
Obviously, self-driving cars are going to
be safer, they're going to save lives.
That is a very important thing.
We want to save lives.
We want the roads to be better.
But the number of lives saved is not the only
term in our ethical calculus.
We have to look at what happened when people
get injured?
How are they taken care of?
How are they able to pay the medical bills
or get back to work, or miss work biochemical
they are recovering but still be able to pay
rent and afford food?
So the question about this is what does this
mean for us as developers?
Like, does this give us a free pass?
We're not liable for IoT devices.
That means we can ship, right?
We can do whatever.
Let's just innovate the hell out of everything
until something breaks, and there is a precedent,
right?
Is that really the legacy that we want to
leave behind?
Do we want to leave the legacy behind of we
did it because we could and we didn't give
a damn about who we hurt?
Some companies are doing this.
Some companies are actually still working
in the space where they just want to innovate,
and they just want to build things, and ship
things, and they will deal with the consequences
later.
But you have to ask yourself: do I want to
be responsible for that?
That's what ethics is all about.
Now, I said that the JavaScript community
had one of the most fascinating ethical incidents
in technology in a while, and that's the left-pad
incident.
I don't know why it is pink, but whatever.
When Ashley talked about left-pad last night,
it was really fascinating because she focused
on a lot of the backlash.
She said the internet blew up when left pad
happened.
People were angry about a lot of things, the
way the JavaScript community developed a small-module
system and maybe it is wrong or maybe it is
right and there's a lot of argument back and
forth and friendships were lost or damaged
in this incident.
And what people didn't realise was that the
reason for all of this anger and acrimony
was because the left-pad incident actually
exposed what is a true ethical dilemma, and
we just didn't see the forest for the trees
at the moment, because left-pad had two competing
ethical decisions.
The first is the hacker culture ethic, that
openness is the most important thing, that
openness is a virtue, and that the ability
to control your code is tantamount to being
a hanger, to being an open-source developer.
Sure, other people can fork it, but you're
going to choose tout it.
When the left-has the broke all his modules
and broke a bunch of stuff on the internet,
MPM had a competing framework that they have
a responsibility to the people who use their
product.
They have a responsibility as engineers.
They also value openness.
They're an open-source community.
So this was a very hard decision, and that's
why there were so many heads being butt over
the decision that was made.
Could you imagine what would have happened
if this didn't happen in 2016 when it mostly
affected the web?
But rather in, I don't know, 2018, 2020 when
MPM is running on people's cars, people's
refrigerators?
Somebody pulls down a module, and now, all
of a sudden, you're driving on the highway
at 70 miles an hour and your car shuts off
and something goes wrong.
You think that couldn't ever happen.
Nobody would ever actually do live deployments
on a car running an IoT device running in
the field.
Please, like we're doing it in production
systems right now.
IoT security is a mess.
We're doing this rapid innovation pace.
Of course there's going to be issues.
And you don't want to be the person that's
responsible for somebody's refrigerator going
out and they lose all their food or maybe
they lose their important medicine that needs
refrigeration.
You don't want to be responsible for that
- or maybe you do.
Maybe you think that the virtue of openness
is the more important ethic and that is a
true ethical dilemma.
So what do we do as jeers?
What are the takeaways that we can have when
we talk about ethics?
This is kind of why I wanted to not give this
talk and rather empower you to be able to
give this talk, because there are actionable
things that we can do as engineers, as developers,
to make our workspaces better, to act with
more ethics.
The first would be to set expectations with
your boss.
If you know what pressures your boss has,
if they ask you to do something you don't
feel comfortable with, you need to know, can
I go to my boss and I don't feel comfortable
with this?
Can you go to your manager and say, "I have
concerns over this?"
Do you know what process will happen if you
do that?
That is an important thing.
You also have to be prepared to say no.
If somebody comes to you and says, "Hey, I
need you to build in this method that sends
tracking data on somebody's heart rate back
to our server in real time," are you comfortable
doing that?
Maybe you're not.
But do you know how to refuse an order?
Are you willing to refuse an order, to put
your career in jeopardy for doing so if it
goes against something that you believe in?
You need also to be able to hold frank discussions
with your co-workers about what this means.
I work in finance, and I'm a data scientist,
so we have a vast amount of data on people,
and a vast amount of capability to do things
with that data, and so, we talk often, my
team, about the implications of what we are
doing when we record customer data, when we
record information about their finances.
We talk all the time, like what are you not
willing to do?
What are we legally obligated to do?
In finance, we have legal obligations in terms
of reporting fraud and in terms of looking
for money-laundering, for example.
So we have to talk about these things with
each other.
And, as engineers, you should be able to talk
frankly with your co-workers like, "I don't
like where this is going."
How do we make sure it doesn't go there?
How do we make sure it stays on the safe side
and not the dangerous side?
The most important thing is to know your limit.
It's to know when you're willing to talk away.
Because tech is really lucrative and we have
a lot of privilege.
We have a lot of privilege in tech.
Even just look around the space that we are
in, this is a remarkable conference in a remarkable
space, and there are amenities and all sorts
of decadence here.
Not all industries are like this.
What is your limit where you would be willing
to say, "I can no longer in good conscience
continue to do this"?
And go do something different.
If you don't know what that limit is, you're
not going to discover that you're over it
until it is too late.
That's all I have.
Thank you very much.
[Applause].
[Cheering].
>> Thank you, Emily.
That was a spectacular talk.
I think you touched on a lot of really important
points for the current ethical questions we
should be asking.
We're going to get set up with the next speaker.
Hold tight, and we will be right with you.